bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et échanger sur des
sujets qui font l'actualité et ce soir
on va parler de la sédentarité des
jeunes plus de 80 % des adolescents
scolarisés au niveau mondial font moins
d'une heure d'activité physique par jour
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé en 2019
en france seulement 5% des enfants
suivent ces mêmes recommandations alors
pourquoi une telle sédentarité comment
lutter contre ce manque d'activité on en
parle avec nos invités
roxane lavergne bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes directrice académique adjointe en
charge des sujets liés à le ps à la
déesse des haines des yvelines et
docteur alain frère bonsoir voila vous
êtes médecin du sport au centre
hospitalier intercommunal de poissy
saint germain en laye alors je voudrais
qu'on débute avec quelques chiffres de
la drees l'agencé nationale de sécurité
sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail
66 % des jeunes de 11 à 17 ans présente
un risque sanitaire préoccupant 49% un
risque sanitaire très élevé des chiffres
donc liés à la sédentarité l'inactivité
physique dr frais la ss alertent les
pouvoirs publics sur la nécessité de
promouvoir et de renforcer l'activité
physique dès l'adolescence qui est une
période charnière qu'est ce qui en fait
une période charnière
c'est même avant il faut effectivement
le faire à l'adolescence mais faut les
démarrer bien en amont c'est à dire dès
la petite enfance c'est pas pour rien
qu'on initie dans pas mal de fédérations
système de baby activité si je puis dire
pour faire bouger les enfants dès le
début et je vais donc la perche la
période charnière évidemment puisque
s'ils valent de croissance lors de cette
période de croissance
wanda mois déjà de bizet il faut qu il
bouge il faut pas qu'ils restent dans
une inactivité qui va l'entraîner dans
une sédentarité progressive et que je
rappelle quand même que c'est quand même
à cet âge là entre 11 et 17 ans que on
apprend ce mode on doit faire derrière
d'ailleurs si on les apprend pas à
bouger là ils vont de moins en moins
bouger et ça sera de plus en plus
difficile de les faire bouger quand ils
auront 18 ans 19 ans 20 points donc il
faut le faire dès le plus jeune âge et
même commencé avant l'adolescence
donc on le fait dans pas mal comme je
voulais dit fédération où on peut
accueillir des enfants dès l'âge de 4 5
ans ils ont en adaptant l'activité bien
évidemment s'agit pas d'aller faire de
la compétition dès le début et le plus
jeune âge et de démarrer de l'activité
pour les initier à la qualité physique
puisque c'est effectivement ça qu'il
faut faire des débuts c'est le 20
janvier dernier vous étiez aussi
auditionné au sénat autour de cette
question de la sédentarité et vous
disiez qui sera plus facile pour un
sujet qui est dans une affection de
longue durée mais qui a fait peu
d'activité physique dans sa jeunesse que
pour une personne qui n'en a jamais fait
auparavant
ça permet aussi quand on commence jeune
le long terme plus tard exactement ce
qu'on a rappelé à nos sénateurs c'est
qu'effectivement le sport santé ou la
prescription son ordonnance de
l'activité physique
il ya tout un réseau comme vous le savez
qui s'est développée en ile-de-france
mais en france également à chaque région
entre guillemets son réseau l'idée c'est
de prescrire de l'activité physique
certes les personnes qui sont en a aidé
c'est à dire des affections de longue
durée qui sont obèses qui ont les
attentions et maintenant l'activité l'an
on est en train de suivre des gens qui
ont été atteints ducobu atteindra comme
idée qui ont des séquelles notamment
pulmonaires ou éventuellement à vider
cardiaque et qu'il faut les réadapter à
l'activité physique je ne parle même pas
de sport c'est déjà les rect les
réhabituer à déjà avoir une activité
normale essayer de marcher correctement
il y en a qui sont vraiment essoufflé
dans les séquelles de la de la colline
donc chez les enfants bien évidemment
chez les personnes qui ont une une
maladie chronique
l' avantage c'est quand ils ont déjà
pratiqué est en jeu c'est beaucoup plus
facile de leur redonner le goût à
l'activité physique parce qu'ils ont une
culture quand il était quand il était
jeune delà de faire cette activité
physique et comme il était comme il
avait du mal effectivement a continué de
l'activité physique pour une raison
particulière d'être familiale
professionnelle et autres ou leur
maladie qui disons qu'ils ont eu l'idée
c'est de permettre à l'activité physique
à peupler difficile quand on en a jamais
fait parce qu'on se dit toujours ce
n'est pas pour moi c'est pour les autres
et donc il faut les réinitié à bouger
tout simplement et c'est pour ça qu'on a
tout un réseau d'enseignants n'a pas qui
m toutes ces personnes à l'activité les
avons nous dévaluer et testé que ce soit
par le médecin traitant ou que ce soit
par les centres de référence comme le
nôtre dans les yvelines nord donc
apprécié saint germain ont fait une
évaluation donc de tout ce qui est
l'activité physique
en fait je les évalue comme j'ai dit au
sénat on les évalue de la même manière
qu'un sportif de haut niveau
si on est effectivement sur des
capacités qu'ils soient moindres 50 fois
moindre car sportifs de haut niveau et
on permet de pouvoir s'adapter à un haut
niveau de l'activité physique
donc il faut il faut le faire il faut
que bouger je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
études de niveau de l'om est ce qu'il
démontre que l'activité physique elle
est primordiale pour l'ensemble de la
population
quel que soit l'âge quel que soit le
niveau quelle que soit la pathologie
qu'on a en face de nous il faut essayer
de
les leur proposer une activité physique
et je parle pas je les biens dits de
sport c'est déjà l'activité justement et
roxanne lavergne au sein de l'académie
de versailles dans le département des
yvelines est ce que vous ressentez ce
manque d'activité chez chez les élèves
oui tout à fait la sédentarité des
enfants et des adolescents est un enjeu
de santé publique vous l'avez dit c'est
aussi un enjeu pour l'école de
nombreuses études ont souligné que nos
jeunes avec une moins bonne forme
physique que leurs aînés et on s'est
saisie voilà de ce triste constat qui
était renforcée par la période de
confinement que nous avons traversées
pour s'attaquer au problème et proposer
justement différents dispositifs quoi
parce qu'être en bonne santé c'est une
condition préalable fondamentale pour
bien apprendre à tous en tête la
citation voilà du bénin à santé c'est un
esprit sain dans un corps sain
donc c'est pour cela que le ministère
d'éducation nationale qui est militaire
d'alger précédé sport également à
inventer à essayer fahva l'ancien
dispositif
avec l'aide du comité d'organisation des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques qui se
nomme 30 minutes d'activité physique
quotidienne à l'école parce qu'il faut
le docteur freud disait il faut prendre
de bonnes habitudes dès le plus jeune
âge
effectivement on va essayer de
ritualiser des pratiques quotidien qui
vont donner l'habitude à nos jeunes à
nos enfants de pratiquer régulièrement
une activité sportive qui n'est pas
forcément du sport vous avez eu raison
tout à l'heure docteur de souligner
qu'il ne s'agit pas de faire 30 minutes
en plus de sport tous les jours puisque
nos enfants ont déjà trois heures
par semaine d'activités sportives il
s'agit de bouger tout simplement en tout
cas de d'avoir une activité que ce soit
pendant les récréations
on a tous se jouer à chat quand on était
plus jeunes alors pour nos enfants
actuellement si vous leur dites jouer à
chat et on vous regarde avec des gros
yeux ronds parce que vous posez plus
poule renard vipère que je voulais
achats mais peu importe
aménager des espaces dans la cour de
récréation on a songé à aménager des
zones il y aurait une tonne pour la
balle au prisonnier une zone pour la
course voilà de manière à leur permettre
de prendre l'habitude de pratiquer une
activité donc hier sportives ou bien une
activité tout simplement en tout cas
être plus actifs qu'ils ne le sont
actuellement
ces pistes donc c'est la récréation
c'est aussi des expérimentations on a
essayé dans certaines écoles puisque le
dispositif s'adresse majoritairement aux
écoles élémentaires à essayer donc
expérimenté dans des écoles en
particulier des cours le matin et
uniquement du sport l'après-midi ou que
là c est en phase d'expérimentation et
on en tirera les leçons prochainement et
on a différents partenariats vous
parliez tout à l'heure docteur des
fédérations sportives
nous nous appuyons également sur ses
fédérations bien entendu à l'aide de
convention depuis 2010 9 avons signé
plus d'une trentaine de conventions avec
des fédérations dans tous les domaines
que ce soit dans des domaines habituel
on va dire comme le rugby le foot aulas
et nous avons aussi du badminton du golf
du cyclisme voilà les différentes
l'activité les passerelles qui existent
entre l'école et une activité sportive
puis sur le périscolaire dr free on le
voit il ya des solutions qui sont mises
en place dans les établissements
scolaires mais est-ce que c'est
l'éducation nationale de prendre cette
question en compte
il faut aussi sensibiliser les parents
on part nous sommes une génération
écrans aujourd'hui
voyez vous les avez raison c'est vrai
qu'on aille encore plus mordant le
malheureusement cette période sanitaire
où on a beaucoup de regrets et des
corans vision donc on bouge peu et
beaucoup moins en tout cas il faut que
sensibiliser tout le monde sait dès le
plus jeune âge comme je voulais dit et
vous l'avez rappelé madame la maire
c'est vrai qu'il faut que ça parte de la
scolarité dès le plus jeune âge et des
la même avant l'arrivée ou au collège ça
se fasse en maternelle il faut apprendre
tout le monde il faut il faut apprendre
à tout le monde à bouger correctement à
pratiquer une activité physique à faire
éventuellement un sport s'il tentait
qu'on a envie d'en refaire un blanc tout
cas bouge il faut que les conditions
soient réunies aussi le succès par
système scolaire également et c'est vrai
que quand vous avez l'activité physique
et à 8 heures du matin qu'il faut déjà
faire une demi heure pour se rendre dans
le gymnase et que la plupart des jeunes
n'ont pas mangé parce qu'ils se sont
réveillés rapidement c'est compliqué
d'aller faire de la vraie activité
physique donc les expérimentations qui
sont fait un peu comme le système
allemand qui est globalement basé sur
les cours le matin et l'activité
physique et culturelles l'après midi ça
peut être une bonne alternative
après je me suis toujours posé la
question pourquoi on était l'activité
physique et à 8 heures du matin
notamment chez les jeunes alors qu'on
pourrait le faire
de trois heures après ils les mettent
plutôt en fin de matinée qui n'ont que
ça à cause des problèmes que ça voudrait
dire tout le monde fait de l'activité
physique à ce moment-là domina que nos
enseignants le ps ils puissent de
travail et surtout de la journée donc
avoir des horaires qui commence dès le
matin sauf que commencer à 8 heures une
activité physique compliqué ça voudrait
dire que le pain bis lève à cinq six
heures pour manger avoir quelque chose
dans le ventre ou à refaire l'activité
physique
donc ça entraîne plein de comportement
et le changement de comportement à côté
je sais qu'on peut faire du sport à jeun
le matin mais plus compliqué il faut
s'entraîner pour ça et là en dessous
donc l'activité physique dès le matin 8
heures compliquées sur le gamin qui
s'est réveillée trois quarts d'heure
avant qui a cavalé comme un malade pour
finir avec un seul cas pas forcément
manger parce que je m'aperçois dans les
bilans je peux faire moi je sais pas mal
de jeunes
il y en a plein qui ne mange pas le
matin donc il ya toute cette éducation
la refaire et pourquoi pas un moment
donné voir a effectivement avec
l'éducation nationale comment est-ce
qu'on peut organiser cette activité
physique de manière à ce que on est plus
de chances qu'elle soit suivie
heureusement tout y est ah bon fort
heureusement tous tous les courts de ps
ne commence pas à 8 heures quand même le
souci du du rythme de l'enfant et on
essaye de le mettre sur des plages
horaires où comme vous dites voilà une
pratique serait plus bénéfique à nous à
nos jeunes
toutefois vous avez raison alors c'est
moi le problème des emplois du temps des
enseignants que le problème des
structures puisque une école ou un
collège soit ont leur propre structure
ce qui est une grande chance soit
partagent les structures sportives avec
la municipalité et dans ce cas là il ya
plusieurs établissements qui se
partagent les plateaux sportifs et ma
foi il faut bien exploité toutes les
plages de la journée y compris y compris
les matinales ça relève aussi d'une
éducation vous mentionnez peut-être plus
au déjeuner le matin et des actions
aussi
l'hygiène de vie et d action baptisée
petit déjeuner qui existe dans les
écoles pour expliquer aux enfants qui un
petit déjeuner équilibré et bien c'est
important on leur explique en un
ils consistent surtout qu'est ce qu'un
petit déjeuner équilibré donc il ya des
actions en ce sens et donc tout effet
voilà pour que normalement le rythme de
l'enfant soit le plus respecté possible
alors nous chaque semaine on pose la
question on pose une question à nos
téléspectateurs celle de cette semaine
c'est avez vous du mal à proposer de
l'activité physique à vos enfants
on répond on nous répond oui à 57 % mais
docteur frais j'aimerais que vous
préciser tout à l'heure vous la verrez
vite à plusieurs reprises faire de
l'activité physique ce n'est pas faire
du sport on a plein d'autres solutions
bah oui il n'ya pas qu'eux alors quand
je dis je ce sport je parle plutôt
compétition et etc
donc on n'est pas obligé de faire
systématiquement du sport a visé le
compétition même si à un moment donné on
peut prendre goût etc
quand je prends tout ce qu'on peut
proposer comme activité physique pour
toutes les personnes qui ont des
pathologies chroniques et à qui on leur
propose une activité physique ça peut
être simplement de la marche
le truc tout ça me dire je suis à je
suis à 500 m 1 km d'indicés d'un collège
autre est plutôt que le prendre le bus
notre dire i à pied avec tout ce que ça
pourrait comporter comme tanger goûte
bien alors à pied et pas le bus je
l'entends et je peux le concevoir mais
il faut essayer de bouger dès qu'on peut
quoi donc
pourquoi prendre la voiture pour faire
juste un kilomètre pourquoi et c'est
pourquoi prendre l'ascenseur quand il ya
des escaliers à côté enfin bref c'est
tous les gestes quotidiens qu'on peut
essayer d'éviter il ya des jeunes qui me
disent de temps en temps mais mais notre
ascenseur dans le lycée ils marchent pas
des regards je leur dise pas grave vous
prenez les escaliers
ça vous fera du bien ah ouais mais mon
cartable et lourds david d'accord pour
cartel bigourdan tenez bon voilà donc je
te ferai pas de petit mot pour dire tu
as doit de prendre l'ascenseur alors que
trop car tu es nul est très lourd et un
peu mal au togo donc il ya des solutions
à trouver
il faut les faire bouger alors le mieux
c'est effectivement avec de l'activité
physique qui l'encadré
soit par un prof de ps va parader du
catr sportive dans un club dès lors
qu'ils ont une appétence pour tel ou tel
type de sport etc après effectivement il
faut qu'ils y viennent régulièrement et
que ce soit intégré dans leur cursus et
scolaires et physiquement donc on en a
des solutions alors actuellement les
solutions on les développe plutôt avec
le développement du sport santé chez les
chez les personnes qui ont donné ces
sites mais ont pour l adapter sur
d'autres personnes qui ont peu de sport
pour lequel la culture sport c'est pas
leur truc mais de réapprendre à bouger
dans la vie comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure
même sur de l'activité physique de
marche tout simplement d'aller inventé
la poudre là dedans mais tout ça ça peut
être encadrés ça peut être proposée il
faut que ça se voit proposer à tous dans
leur box al nahyane on l'a dit vite fait
tout à l'heure le contexte sanitaire de
cette année et particuliers lakovic 19
nous a interrompu sur beaucoup et
d'activité et notamment les activités
extra scolaires qui se sont raréfiés
tout ce qui est en intérieur est
quasiment interdite reprend un petit peu
est-ce que l'académie est plus attentive
encore peut-être cette année c'est vrai
que depuis le 18 janvier dernier les
activités donc sportive en intérieurs
ont été suspendus à cause voilà la
propagation de lakovic 19 toutefois moi
je tiens à souligner l'imagination et
l'adaptabilité de nos professeurs
d'éducation physique et sportive ou un
dynamisme remarquable parce qu'ils ont
su s'adapter et proposer des activités
justement aux jeunes en tenant compte
des contraintes bien évidemment de
mourir husky à la crise sanitaire est
vraiment ils ont proposé d'autres
activités pour éviter le brassage
d'élèves faire des parcours différé ou
bien faire plus demain je parlais de
marche en lançant des des concours alors
non pas des compétitions puisque vous
l'avez dit les compétitions ont été
annulés mais faire des compétitions à
distance voilà des battles
une battle randonnée qui a été organisée
certains collèges où ça serait au
collège qui marcherait le plus de
kilomètres pour emporter cette fameuse
bataille donc vraiment une grande
imagination de la part de nos
professeurs qui ont eu à coeur vraiment
de maintenir une activité et de
s'adapter vous alors besoin de nos
jeunes vous mentionniez tout à l'heure
docteur le fait qu' on évite de
suspendre toute activité il ya une
véritable adaptation d'éducation
nationale je trouve ces dernières années
sur ce point puisque auparavant
lorsqu'un enfant avait une pathologie
quelconque ils étaient dispensés de
sport voilà qu'on avait ce terme là sur
lui et sur les certificats maintenant
vraiment on demande
l'institution demande aux médecins et
ils suivent à 200% vraiment spécifié
pour l type de pratiques
l'enfant ne peut pas enfin quel type de
pratique l'ensemble peut pas pratiquer
pas bon je le répète tout simplement
parce que ça permet aux professeurs de
proposer autre chose
un enfant qui ne va pas pouvoir courir
peut-être qu'effectivement il va pouvoir
quand même jouer au basket ball mais en
marchant en tout cas une adaptation lui
ai proposé de manière à le faire
participer à ne pas l'exclure du groupe
et si vraiment il ne peut pas pratiquer
bien au moins il peut arbitrer et en
tout cas il n'est pas coupée du groupe
est vraiment inclus dans toutes les facs
justement docteur fois je voudrais
rebondir à cette notion il ya des sports
des activités pour lesquelles part nous
ne sommes pas fait mais on n'a pas
nécessairement d'appétence particulière
est ce que votre que médecin il faut
vous priverez préconisé qu'on aille chez
son médecin peut-être généralistes pour
évaluer les possibilités qu'ont puis
qu'on peut faire avec notre physique nos
capacités sportives
exactement c'est là sa part du médecin
traitant on connaît très bien son
patient et la famille l'idée c'est
effectivement qu'il évalue alors soit il
est capable de l'évaluer parce qu'il
n'ya pas de pathologie on va dire lourd
nécessitera une investigation un peu
plus coup c'est vraiment le réseau
prescrit forme
de l'île de france a c'est ça c'est à
dire tous passent pas par nous au niveau
du centre de référence
il est évident ça passe par médecin
traitement c'est ce qu'on dit déjà dit
plusieurs fois comme mes collègues il ya
d'autres médecins traitement
c'est-à-dire vous évaluer les capacités
de votre passion vous avez en face de
vous quelqu'un soit l'âge soit il n'y a
pas grand chose et vous prescrivez de
l'activité physique où vous l'auriez pas
si tu peux faire si tu peux faire ça y'a
pas de problème s'il est le médecin
traitant a le moindre souci dans
l'évaluation ou le type de pratiques
qu'on pourrait le faire faire à 100
patients qui présentent ou non une
pathologie d'ailleurs c'est
effectivement de nous l'a dressé pour
que nous puissions faire sur plateau
technique une évaluation complète de ses
capacités le médecin traitant est tenu
au courant et ensuite le patient rentre
dans la filière avec les enseignants n'a
pas qu'ils prennent en charge et qui
démarque quelque chose et ensuite sa
part dans le réseau des éducateurs ou
été formés par le chef des sports et qui
peuvent ensuite les prendre en charge
dans certains pans certaines fédérations
dans certains camps certains clubs voilà
tout ça c'est un peu long vous en doutez
à mettre en place il ya une grosse
formation qui est fait par jeunesse et
sports et par le comité départemental
olympique de former tous ces enseignants
qu'ils soient éducateurs coach et autres
pour pouvoir mettre en place de ce suivi
de patients qui ont besoin de se
remettre à l'activité physique notamment
s'ils vont en plus une pathologie
chronique et ça nécessite qui est tout
un réseau derrière et une évaluation de
tout ce qu'on met en place au niveau du
centre de référence trop ordinaire
qu'est ce que c'est que je ne vous ai
pas posé la question mais quelles sont
les principales conséquences pour un
jeune de ne pas faire d'activité
physique
ah bah vous avez raison de poser la
question qu'est ce qui va se passer
qu'est ce qui va se passer il ya
effectivement une prise de poids c'est
clair il va se faire progressivement une
alors prise de poids ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire effectivement des problèmes
après l'aide articulaires de surpoids
on peut avoir des problèmes cardiaques
qui apparaissent des problèmes
respiratoires qui apparaissent un
malaise sur plan de la santé mentale
on parle également puisque ça en fait
partie et dans cette arche et dans cette
période de croissance d'adolescence
on sait qu'il faut être assez vigilant
il à vis de ses enfants qui se sentent
pas bien dans leur cour quelle qu'en
soit la raison ou la cause qu'elles
soient familiales ou autres et qu'il
faut effectivement s'en occupe et donc
il ya pas mal d'effets secondaires à ne
pas bouger la plus que à bouger donc
quand on regarde la part des choses et
la balance entre les deux il faut mieux
effectivement proposer une activité
physique assez jeune on avait fait
d'ailleurs quand il c'est vous qui
l'aviez évoqué mais j'avais pu l'évoquer
au sénat de dire que j'avais pas attendu
évidemment qu'on fasse on fasse tout
seul
ce développement du sport santé puisque
dans les années fin des années 90 2000
j'avais déjà ici au sein du service de
médecine du sport et en place tout un
circuit avec lyon qui est l'hôpital où
il ya tous les enfants google
d'ile-de-france qui me sont on avait
commencé avec la pédiatre de mettre en
place tout un circuit pour les évaluer
donner des informations à un kiné ou je
me souviens plus si c'était un kiné ou
un déjà instable
formé à l'activité physique qui les
prenaient en charge derrière pendant
leur séjour à bullion ou évidemment
vérifier toute la diététique le
psychologique etc etc et on les faisait
déjà bougé avec des programmes qui
faisait par rapport à l'évaluation
contre l'ailé droite ils le font encore
avec vos collègues de rambouillet si ma
mémoire est bonne et on sait que la mère
n'avait effectivement et les actions qui
seront plus en plus donc ça me lavergne
on en parlait aussi ça peut amener un
manque de confiance chez les jeunes et
l'urss avec avec vous l'urss fait une
caravane santé des petits défis
physiques où ils sont en mesure de se
rendre compte qu'ils peuvent faire les
choses tout à fait en fait le nss donc
nous nationale
hors scolaires annie en place donc cette
fameuse caravane santé qui à ce jour a
s'est rendu dans 26 établissements des
yvelines et cette caravane sans effet
pas séance test perd on a des jeunes
collégiens
c'est des tests par exemple ça peut être
le but du forcement abdominale ça peut
être ça peut être l'exercice de la
chaise pour tester aussi leur endurance
pour plein de petits tests rapides de
quelques quelques minutes et à la fin
ils ont un résultat avec un code couleur
c'est à dire que s'ils sont un code
rouge a bien évidemment c'est mauvais
signe et ils sont très mauvaise forme
physique il va falloir qu'ils y remédie
ou bien un symbole john ou bien c'est un
symbole faire et hélas nous sommes
rendus compte la presser 26 tests des
établissements ou bézy vinh que
malheureusement un car de jeunes étaient
en mauvaise forme physique dans bnsf se
saisit de cela pour en parler bien
entendu
et puis les jeunes qui sont plus en plus
sensibilisé tout de même à une bonne
hygiène de vie grâce aux réseaux sociaux
c'est ma foi une bonne influence des
réseaux sont ils sont très sensibles
voilà ce set
cette hygiène de vie qui se doivent
d'avoir d'être en bonne santé
s'ils veulent voilà bien vivre et donc
on leur propose des activités en
fonction de leurs résultats ces tests et
une reprise
alors soit une reprise en douceur son
contraire un renforcement de leurs
activités physiques lan tout cas c'est
un programme qui est adapté aux tests
qu'ils ont passés alors ayant quelques
secondes docteur fou on va terminer avec
vous on est bien d'accord
il n'est jamais trop tard pour commencer
exactement c'est ce qu'ont fait
d'ailleurs avec les personnes qui sont
atteintes de pathologies chroniques qui
n'ont jamais fait d'activité physique
pour maintenant l'avoir bien développée
depuis maintenant trois quatre ans au
sein de ce service et avec l'aide de nos
enseignants n'a pas on s'aperçoit que
effectivement des personnes prennent
goût à l'activité physique
ils font pas de sport en lisant 55 60 70
ans et des pathologies
qui leur sont tombés dessus si je puis
dire et le fait de découvrir leur corps
est apprendre à bouger
si en plus ils n'ont jamais fait la
branche peux vous dire que c'est un
véritable bonheur pour eux et on a
l'impression non pas de les guérir de
leur pathologie parce qu'on n'est pas là
pour les guérir mais en tout cas les
aider à supporter cette pathologie
parfois même à diminuer la consommation
de médicaments liés à cette pathologie
et donc ils se sentent mieux donc il
faut qu'on continue à à le faire donc ça
marche là et tout bas chez les jeunes il
faut effectivement l'a dit depuis le
début de l'émission faut pour
effectivement les faire bouger ça je je
continuerai à pousser dans cette voie là
toutes les initiatives ou à les faire
bouger et on va s'arrêter sur ces mots
merci à tous les deux d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation le 7-8 société
maintenant terminée on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine prenez soin de vous
[Musique]